Nos piden resolver para "x" y nos dan esta ecuación radical,
1 es igual a la raíz principal o raíz cuadrada positiva
de "x" sobre 3 menos 2.
Una manera de hacer esto,
es dejar de un lado la expresión radical
elevar al cuadrado y finalmente despejar "x",
esta es la manera más directa
y por lo general obtenemos más de una solución,
por lo cual, hay que probar las soluciones
en la ecuación original a ver si funcionan.
En otros vídeos he explicado porqué en ocasiones
obtenemos soluciones
que de hecho no llegan a funcionar,
pero resolvamos esta, debe de salir directa,
así es que lo primero para eliminar es este 2,
vamos a sumar 2 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
sumamos 2 a la izquierda y sumamos 2 a la derecha ¿Qué tenemos?
Del lado izquierdo,
1 más 2 es igual a 3
y del lado derecho -2 y más 2 se cancelan,
y nos queda tan solo
raíz principal de "x" sobre 3.
Ahora multipliquemos por 3
ambos lados de la ecuación,
multiplicamos por 3 el lado derecho
y multiplicamos por 3 el lado izquierdo.
Del lado izquierdo resulta 3 por 3 = 9
y del lado derecho, 3 entre 3 se cancelan
y nos queda simplemente la raíz cuadrada de "x"
y ahora simplemente elevamos al cuadrado,
ambos lados de la ecuación.
Elevamos entonces al cuadrado del lado izquierdo
y elevamos al cuadrado del lado derecho,
del lado izquierdo nos queda
9 al cuadrado es igual a 81
y del lado derecho nos queda "x".
Obtuvimos una sola solución
probemosla,
sustituyámosla en la ecuación original
y veamos si funciona.
Evaluemos el lado derecho con "x" igual a 81
y verifiquemos que esto es igual a 1.
Tomamos entonces la raíz principal de 81 sobre 3,
este es el valor de "x" que estamos tomando,
-2
¿Y so cuánto es?
La raíz principal de 81, es la raíz cuadrada positiva,
esto es 9 sobre 3 menos 2,
9 entre 3, esto nos da 3.
Finalmente 3 menos 2 es igual a 1,
de hecho, es igual a 1,
así es que efectivamente "x" igual a 81
es una solución válida de la ecuación radical.